how's it going real my name is Pierre
bad
welcome to treaty Minds chapter 1 and
using some Authority you don't know what
happened you are trapped in a house in
somewhere we're gonna be the only member
you have this you have a bro hey I love
that face is like rally really he always
wanna pose in front of the cat rap
always but no not today because today I
don't even know but anyway
videos would probably be up a little
sooner today I usually like to upload my
videos because they're horror a bit
later and I think it fits better but
today I have a best day I'm gonna be the
jury and like a parade there in
Gothenburg xym Achtung Wow what's going
on over there Martin thank you for the
tinderbox I don't know why exactly
ah yeah oh there is body cool
I grabbed ah if done without his
and that just makes a damn sex object
right there look at this nabobs good dad
oh the [ __ ] ah
spin the wheel Betty oh hell no God you
did that [ __ ] Enya that all triple what
uh Alice Bailey yeah well you scared why
I'm not I'm just here for it Hauser's
wait a second pipes on Thompson sorry
buddy
what were you doing with those people
Zapata I've done that baby I just woke
up they kidnap they get on me
that's right look at you oh hell no ah
hell nah hell nah hell nah hell nah
Sharma Lachman
whoa whoa whoa he's for all right Oh
all right let's go this way this guys
are saying Scott Brown bad air Jala back
his nipples are huge
I got a crook oh [ __ ]
clap Dan I hate that [ __ ] you have to
carry on my wayward son there'll be
peace when you are done where's the
fauna where are all of you go god damn
it why would they keep a locked door
like that that's not cool taking Stefano
with me jumping my way over heat all
right you little buzzy why why would you
call me that I don't care this keep
going pity it will be okay nice [ __ ]
barrels stop blocking my way you little
Oh don't test me don't you dare test
that's right that's right I jump higher
than you put it I goddamn it what is
this [ __ ] say there's Pato I'm gonna
[ __ ] you up [ __ ] all that's right you
you're my barrel [ __ ] right now
that's right you will die before you're
rich would never ring the bell it's
weird
so let's find the hammer or whatever ah
it's here cool hey bro I guess you are
still alive reading this I just want to
remind you that memories really chars I
don't hit your head with rauner
humping by the way I left London in the
chest and some drugs in the cloud and
and bro when use some sort of hide in
the college sorry for the world I'm
hungry
yeah that makes sense I guess biggie
yeah I was just taking a nap you know
it's pretty sweet
but yeah oh I feel sexy
yeah like why are you so long big I
don't know a snake haha I wish it yeah
how much neg you thought it was pig no
I'm snake yeah yeah look at that
oh girl I get that back oh no god damn
it it tricked me I'd hit me good I'm
glad I didn't open it and that shitty
way alright let's just take piggy and
going the other [ __ ] shitty floor all
right Peggy get a bump yeah yeah you
gotta go [ __ ] Peggy yeah I fall in slow
motion you know why I tell you why
because he can't stand the side of the
jungle ah they never fight good because
they're never what I'm a rapper now
Peggy I'm in pity whoa you see that
thing I'm a frisbee thought I was you
thought it was Pig no I'm frisbee like
piggy I'll just freak me out a little
bit last call
all right I don't like this room very
much I'm gonna turn on my volume a
little bit all right I need piggy for
this piggy
that's right yeah yeah girl look at that
body
oh girl look at that bye oh all right
I'll let piggy inspect them and then
come on Jesus cries you're slow you uh
if you want to rub my nipples - any time
pootie
you can do it any time buddy any time
all right piggy you make sure it's safe
all right all right Petey go pee
I feel kind of sexy right I'm sure it's
fine all right you're right Thank You
biggie your bra unless that's the fun oh
boy oh hell no
[ __ ] me is coming here all right let's
hide inside I know it's a bad idea
let's do it anyway oh oh oh god damn
that hurts
alright we're good gotta solve [ __ ] I
think we're good
can you go away please
it was a [ __ ] oh it was a pooper are
you guarding here barrels are you
guarding the Thompson oh [ __ ] you barrel
you stay there with him that's right you
cattle with them that's your punishment
get ban that [ __ ] jumps here take em
not me okay I'm Rudy here
all right let's go let's go hey y'all
hey ha ha ha [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm so [ __ ] out of here holy sugar on
the snip - fine huh why did I give you
holy [ __ ] Betty your big vets pissy well
no don't trip go ah dude yeah everywhere
I don't want to die here bro I need to
find you I need a frickin pulsers right
up in this mother f a hunch on a hunch
on unload on John John John
alright here we go girl look at that
body
girl Rabia that's right Daniel Rob does
NEFAs I try they grow and that's how he
stands up the nipples just rip that's
just my opinion of it which you all have
our cakes on it let's go down shall we
maybe there's a log door that I probably
can't open yeah that's good not good it
on cause it place actually I wouldn't
mind having a Chardonnay here all right
there we go give me that [ __ ] that's
right
neither drugs hey how you doing Carl
nice meeting you
I was changed feeling about this room I
should go I'm doing that [ __ ] oh cool
I'm gonna shut fire Thank You mr. chair
bro I die my eyes still changing me good
best voice acting Yuri any action ever
hazing me oh no it's like the typing of
the Dead from yesterday I think oh god
Abed ah what are you doing here boxes hi
I have that box doing that stupid box
what are you doing that okay oh no I
hate forgets like that where he was
there yeah wait a second
goddammit sexy I can never get over it
oh no I think was
I shall use the hammer on [ __ ] you
oh wait my mouse go alright thought
there you are oh [ __ ] you now why do I
share my bed
Gemma oh my god huh I don't know anymore
brother one of these days I tell you not
get it
I heard you screaming a payday are you
okay no I'm not okay I'm an even die
careful baby you could hurt me I'm not
gonna look at you anymore I don't even
know I need that soft Holly [ __ ] this
[ __ ] cuts I'm sorry
it's got them terrifying alright there
we go put you down by put you down put
you down my foot down huh huh oh I'm
spinning yo my name is Farah
I'm with a none action and I want to be
your soprano cuz I am Sofia and oranges
are nice because they don't drive try
anything I'm so stupid
alright I should definite actually maybe
it runs to something I mean oranges
orange Laura Laura
[ __ ] it alright there we go
hots there we go that looks this stupid
[ __ ] you know I don't trust you all you
think you're cute kiss your little baby
statue no you're already untrusted
that's right oh you two better better
believe it buddies you bet
leave that piggy I totally doing to you
why are they doing that that's not cool
all right I think we're done here so we
head down maybe oh no that's not good ha
somebody monster how is it [ __ ] he's fat
we're good oh thank god huh of course
please don't come down here I think it's
a pooper
I think it's a [ __ ] I don't know are
you still a bruh let's just ignore him
for now and go over here and I'm
actually got in here a little earlier
like I said I had really good today so
I'm sometimes I do short videos that's
just how it is but anyway jindo ID my
god Ali screaming ah I can't bear the
view enjoy subscribe come over today and
I'll see you next episode
that's pretty much it careful activate
our challenge he was one of cars
the seven [ __ ] game ever